one of the problems of object detection
as you've learned about it so far is
that your algorithm may find multiple
detections of the same object so rather
than detecting an object just once
it might detect it multiple times
non-mac suppression is a way for you to
make sure that your algorithm detects
each object only once let's go through
an example let's say you want to detect
pedestrians cars and motorcycles in this
image you might place a grid over this
and this is a 19 by 19 grid now while
technically this car has just one
midpoint so it should be assigned just a
one grid cell and the car on the Left
also has just one midpoint so
technically only one of those fit cells
should predict that there is a car in
practice you're running an object
classification and localization
algorithm for every one of these spirit
cells so it's quite possible that
disparate cell might think that the
center of a car is in it and so might
this and so like this and for the car on
the left as well maybe not only this box
if this is a test image you've seen
before
not only that boss might decide that
things has found the car maybe this box
and this box and maybe others as well
will also think that they've found the
car so let's step through an example of
how non-mac suppression will work so
because you're running the image
classification and localization
algorithm on every grid cell on 361 grid
cells is possible that many of them will
raise their hand and say my PC my chance
of thinking I've been objects in it is
large rather than just having two of the
grid cells out of the 19 squared or 361
think they've detected an object so when
you run your algorithm you might end up
with multiple detections of each object
so what non max suppression does is it
cleans up these detection so that you
end up with just one detection per car
rather than multiple detections for a
car
so concretely what it does is it first
looks like the probability is associated
with each of these detections Canada pcs
although there are some details you
learn about in this week's prone
exercise is actually PC times are c1 or
c2 or c3 but for now let's just say is
PC with the probability of detection and
it first takes the largest one which in
this case is 0.9 and says that's my most
confident detection so let's highlight
that I'm just say I found a car there
having done that the non-mac suppression
part then looks at all of the remaining
rectangles and all the ones with a high
overlap with a high I owe you with this
one that you've just output will get
suppressed so those two rectangles with
the 0.6 and the 0.7 both of those
overlap but Lots with the light blue
rectangle so those you're going to
suppress and darken them to show that
they're being suppressed
NIC's you then go through the remaining
rectangles and find the one with the
highest probability the highest PC which
in this case is this one with 0.8 so
let's commit to that and just say oh
I've detector car there and then an on
Mac suppression pod is to then get rid
of any other ones with a higher you so
now every rectangle has been either
highlighted or darkens and if you just
get rid of the darkened rectangles
you're left with just the highlighter
ones and these are your two final
predictions so this is non Mac
suppression and non max means that
you're going to output your maximal
probabilities classifications but
suppress the closeby ones that are non
maximal so that's as a name non max
suppression so let's go through the
details of the algorithm first on this
19 by 19 grid you're going to run you're
going to get a 19 by 19 by 8 output
volume although for this example I'm
going to simplify it to say that you're
only doing car detection so let me get
rid of the C 1 C 2 C 3 and pretend for
this line that each output for each of
the 19 by 19 so for each of the 300
61 which is 19 squared for each other
361 positions you get an output
prediction of the following which is the
chance that there's an object and then
the bounding box and if you have only
one object there's no you know C 1 C 2 C
C prediction the details of what happens
you have multiple objects I'll leave to
the programming exercise which can work
on at towards the end of this week now
to internment non max depression the
first thing you can do is discard all
the boxes let's call all the predictions
all the bounding boxes were PC less than
equal to some threshold let's say 0.6 so
we're gonna say that unless you think
there's at least a 0.6 chance it is an
object there let's just get rid of it so
this is cause all the low probability
output boxes so the way to think about
this is for each of the 361 positions
you output a bounding box together with
a probability of that bounding box being
a good one so we're just going to
discard all the bounding boxes that were
assigned a low probability NIC's while
there any remaining bounding boxes that
you've not yet discarded or process
you're going to repeatedly pick the box
to the highest probability with the
highest PC and then output that as a
prediction so this is a process on the
previous slide of taking one of the
bounding boxes and making it lighter in
color so you commit to outputting that
as a prediction for that there's a car
there next you then discard any
remaining box so any box that you have
not output as a prediction and there was
not previous as is called it so discard
any remaining box with a high overlap
with a high iou with the box that you
just output in the previous step so this
second step in the while loop was when
on the previous slide you were darkened
any remaining bounding box that has a
high overlap with the bounding box that
we just made lighter than we just
highlighted
and so you keep doing this while there's
still any remaining boxes that you've
not yet process until you've taken each
of the boxes and either output it as a
prediction or discarded it as having too
high an overlap or too high in IOU with
one of the boxes that you have just
output as a predicted position for one
of the detected objects I've described
the algorithm using just a single object
on this slide if you actually try to
detect three objects say pedestrians
cause and motorcycles then the output
vector will have three additional
components and it turns out the right
thing to do is to independently carry
out non-mac suppression three times one
on each of the outputs classes but the
details of that I'll leave to this
week's program exercise where you get to
implement that yourself we get to
implement non-mac suppression yourself
on multiple object classes so that's it
for non max suppression and if you
implement the object detection algorithm
we've described you actually get pretty
decent results but before wrapping up
our discussion of the Yolo algorithm
there's just one last idea I want to
share with you which makes the algorithm
work much better which is the idea of
using entire boxes let's go on to the
next video